put on your mast and build your crosses
because it's time to go bowling or
search for a multiple sexually
frustrated homicidal Psychopaths yes
after almost two years David Fincher's
mine hunter season 2 is finally here
so in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into the ending and delving into
some of the details you missed along the
way I'll be coming out with a separate
video in a day or two which we'll deal
exclusively with the real-life serial
killers of season 2 so make sure to
subscribe and stay tuned for that
in the meantime grab your panic attack
pills because here we go the ending of
mine hunter season 2 revolves around the
arrest of Wayne Bertram Williams the
real-life killer who Georgia police
believe is responsible for at least 23
of the 30 Atlanta murders from 1979 to
1981 as the final card says to this day
the vast majority of cases in the
Atlanta murders remain unsolved
but seeing us how the killings stopped
soon after Wayne's arrest and the
damning forensic evidence like carpet
and dog fibers it's highly believed
Wayne was the perpetrator even though he
only ended up being charged for the
murder of two of the victims we open on
the Jackson Parkway bridge where Holden
and Bill have staked out for the night a
few episodes ago a news leak reported
that the authorities have begun matching
carpet fibers to the dead bodies since
then the killer began dumping his body's
in the Chattahoochee River so that such
forensic evidence couldn't be used
against him the only problem is that
stretch of river has multiple points one
could use to dispose of a body so the
police chief has to make the decision to
invest most of his manpower on the
behavioral science units hunch that the
killer will continue to dump bodies in
said River a hunch that pays off after
hearing a splash in the water and upon
noticing the driver turns the other way
once he sees the cops the officers make
their arrest immediately bill and Holden
interrogate the suspect implementing
some of their techniques to see if Wayne
fits their psychological profile you
follow the story closely how it is the
killer Holden and Bill surmise would be
following the case closely in fact
earlier in the season Holden believes
the killer to be using the media to
taunt them
he's body on Sigmund Road because he saw
us on TV he's following the press
taunting us but it's not just wings
interest in the case that raises red
flags for Holden over the course of the
investigation Holden and bill have
created a psychological profile to
narrow down who this killer might
actually be that's the whole point of
the Behavioral Sciences unit to
interview serial killers and build a
database of these profiles if they can
understand how these killers think and
operate the theory goes that they can
better understand on how to capture and
figure out who these killers are when an
innocent man is taken in for questioning
for the murders Wayne lashes out by
dumping another body in the location the
cops had just checked two days earlier
it's his way of saying f you for not
getting credit for the kills it puts him
in control like he's directing the hunt
dropping pews body at a site we've
searched is a way of inserting himself
in the investigation this idea of serial
killers lusting for control is explored
more this season and is one of the
profile traits the BSU have given to
Wayne their killer demands to control
the narrative likes the power of being
in control as we'll see later when Wayne
is outed as a suspect and followed by
the press he uses the power to
manipulate and control the narrative
allowing the press to interview him in
his own home and taking them to the
mayor's house where he taunts the mayor
to come out control for Wayne is
something he never had in his life in
fact he is very little of it he lives
with his parents has to use his uncle's
car and his career isn't going anywhere
in his real life he has no control but
in his fantasy life he craves it the
same is true of other killers we've seen
this season like the Son of Sam killer
David Berkowitz his psychological
profile also included the desire for
control it was only after the paper
started giving him nicknames of which he
disapproved that he reached out to shift
the narrative back in his court sending
letters which refer to him as the Son of
Sam it's this reasoning that Holden
knows the callers claiming to be the
killer were fake if the killer desired
to control the narrative and build his
own mythology why call the police
instead of going straight to the press
but Holden also has several other
telling
Jersey's given to this Atlantic killer
such as him being an african-american
male in his 20s or 30s he has to be a
good talker to lure the kids in he lives
with his parents owns a dog and thinks
he's smarter than everyone else
Queens car and alibi raised serious red
flags for the agents not only are rope
gloves and dog hairs found inside but
winds alibi doesn't check out who goes
to check on a new singer at 3:00 a.m.
but since none of the victims died by
rope and there's no physical evidence to
tie him to any of the murders they have
to let him go it's not about what we
believe is a moment we can prove back in
Virginia things aren't going so well for
the tench family after was discovered
their adopted son participated in the
murder of a toddler
Nancy 10 she has slowly gone downhill in
the beginning of the season she's
cheerful and a regular mourning involves
her making breakfast for her family now
she broods smoking cigarettes and
letting Bill fend for himself when it
comes to breakfast
is there any breakfast no there's cereal
if you want at the end of the season
bill arrives home to find she's packed
up and left she can't handle the way her
son is treated in the constant back
talking of neighbors bill although he's
tried his best has spent most of his
time balancing the case in Atlanta and
his life in Virginia but it's both bill
and Nancy's feelings that they have
somehow contributed to Brian's
involvement in this murder that both of
these characters struggle with was this
inside him what do we got him bill knows
a lot about this in examining serial
killers he's seen how traumatic
childhood events usually the result of
abusive parents have shaped them ed
Kemper for example outlines how his
desire to kill women was the result of
an emotionally and physically abusive
alcoholic mother did bill and Nancy do
something that caused Brian to take part
in such a vicious act or was it in his
very DNA she isn't winning mother of the
year anytime soon back in Atlanta
Holden intent follow-up on Wayne finding
out he does in fact live with his parent
and own a dog perhaps even creepier is
the fact he sends out flyers looking for
young and new talent he's a music
manager who spends his time looking for
the next Michael Jackson while following
up at the Music Studio they find out he
rarely does any recording rather spends
most of his time just talking with the
kid and if that wasn't weird they get
their hands on a composite sketch an
eyewitness took and the resemblance is
uncanny back at the task force holding
surmises that Wayans motivation for the
killings is shame he hates himself so
much that he takes it out on these kids
he's ashamed of his failure to achieve
which is why he exaggerates his music
career and pumps himself up the agents
also learned that he was burning stuff
in his backyard at 5:00 a.m. and that
Wayne also happened to be the crime
scene photographer at one of his victims
own crime scenes they get a warrant to
search his home and not only find the
green carpet fibers from some of his
victims but also a book on how to beat a
lie detector and even though when they
interview him he can't keep his alibi
straight they still must let him go up
until this point there's no proof he did
any of it thus he has to be set free
there's a great scene after Wayne is
released in which he stops to admire the
press something Holden picks up on they
also interview a man by the name of mr.
Marcus a close friend of Wayne's who's
looking for that $100,000 reward he
tells him that one time some people came
up to them asking for donations for the
missing children and that Wayne shooed
them away seeing these kids were a bunch
of prostitutes and not worth their time
or money this sentiment that these kids
somehow deserved it for being hustlers
and giving black folks a bad name is
reiterated two other times once when
interviewed by the press and second when
interviewed by Holden and Bill Jim
Barney their man on the ground in
Atlanta follows wings dad to a nearby
airfield where he finds out he was
inquiring about tickets to South America
hinting that Wayne may be on his way out
of the country it isn't until District
Attorney Slayton is promised a
conviction from the Justice Department
that Wayne is arrested Slayton wanted
his men to make the rest in front of the
press it's politics after all which is
why Holden and Bill didn't even know it
was happening one of the things this
season does well is show how politics
and justice in the American criminal
to system go hand-in-hand take for
example how the Atlanta mayor shooed
away the FBI after he found out they may
have a black predator on the loose
something he didn't want in the
spotlight with an election looming the
case itself as Holden and Bill go on to
note has several unanswered questions
such as the missing Polaroids of young
black men which seemingly vanished from
the Atlanta PD evidence room or why some
of the men with known sexual assault
backgrounds were never investigated
Holden goes to meet the mothers of the
missing children but the arrest of Wayne
is no solace for them they know all too
well the loss of their children will be
used as a publicity stunt to further the
careers of politicians Holden vows he'll
continue to work on the case which is
quickly deflated in the next scene when
he's told by the FBI director that the
cases will soon be classified as
inactive for some justice has been
served for others it has not we also see
dr. Wendy Carr throwing out the
magazines of her now ex-girlfriend
signifying her moving on from that
relationship she's gone on her own
journey of self-discovery this season
becoming more in touch with her
sexuality and more confident in her
place at work even venturing out in
interviewing some of the most infamous
serial killers in America the season
ends just like season one on a character
known as the ADT serviceman or the BTK
killer real-life killer Dennis Rader
we've seen bits and pieces of him over
the course of the season each new
segment giving us a glimpse of who this
man is and what makes him tick in a way
these short segments are giving us the
viewer our own psychological profile of
who this man really is considering
season 1 used this same technique it's
possible they may continue this next
season as Rader wasn't even caught until
2005 if and how the show decides to
incorporate him into the main storyline
remains to be seen but it seems they
were setting him up to be the main
antagonist for a future season if you
want to know more about the BTK killer
i'll be talking about him in my
real-life killers of minehunters season
2 video that's it for this video if you
liked it make sure to LIKE and subscribe
you can also follow me on twitter at
things story YT and
Bure daddy loves you very much